so welcome Jeremy thank you for coming
in to talk to us of course I can't wait
to see what you've got yes so what we've
got here is essentially a to-do list /
calendar app okay um and I just like you
to take a look at this and try to make a
new event nunu sorry a new task okay so
looking at the homepage I see I've got
this sign in button so that's a nice
different color all very obvious let me
hit it alright so now I'm in the main
screen of the application and I see I've
got this big button right here so I bet
that creates a new new task alright I've
got a new untitled task see if I can
give it a name are this the prototype
the text fields are yes the text fields
aren't working right now I can see that
you want to be able to use them you know
you want to type in things so I want to
click through all of these and then hit
the big create button yep awesome okay
so you've made the made a new event
that's awesome that's all right clear
now I can you just sort of navigate
through the app see if there's anything
that makes sense to you as an extra
feature you see if there's anything that
you want to explore how would you go
about exploring this app first off well
let me just scroll down all right so
I've got my list of tasks there's
nothing else down there let me see if I
can move back and forth to the days i
presume on the full app that elapsed i
would work but right now we don't have
that well the only other thing that
actually to explore is on this menu
button up at the top so let's see what
we've got ok ok got a bunch of different
options should I just pick one or yeah
sure just explore a little bit um one
thing that I want to see especially is
your reactions to certain these pages so
you know the overview page ok um the
calendar pages well let's check out the
overview page first ok so I have these
lists of I assume these are different
collections of tasks that I've done
stuff with in the past and then some
graph of I guess how often I've snooze
things how often I've completed things
all right be a useful thing to you as
somebody who's going to use to do apps
not really i don't particularly care
about when i completed tasks i just you
know want to look at my my current list
of tasks that i have to do awesome so
can you go back and find your current
list of tasks so I think home probably
taking there yep so this is everything I
need to do today this is you know
kind of my primary mode of interaction
with a to-do list app I think perfect
and if you wanted to check off a test
you know say you've finished your
meeting with Jacqueline how would you go
about doing that well it looks like
there's this big empty box which I
imagine is a check box okay yeah and in
the final lap when you click that that
would check off and something would
happen there what would you expect to
happen when you hit that check box um I
would imagine it which is kind of like
anime out of the list and the other
events would slide up and slide into
place awesome go thank you yeah so
you've given us great feedback I
appreciate your time absolutely this is
fun perfect thank you jeremy